ciao a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video sono fa vj e
dolcissimo su gir
ragazzi che un videogame che è stato
fatto dagli stessi geni geni che hanno
fatto comunque ragazzi gip
l'avevo già giocato altre volte ma avevo
soltanto messo degli spezzoni di video
cioè non ce lo ha mai dedicato un video
soltanto a questo quel che secondo me
merita un casino che vi dico soltanto
ragazzi che come gioco e imposti
consiste nello scalare una montagna
arrampicandosi prima che l'acqua ti
prenda ma è impossibile io ve lo dico è
impossibile il mio record attuale era tv
a 14.4 che non so se un record buono non
ne ho idea non voglio neanche saperlo
che i ragazzi sono già partiti non mi
ricordo neanche come si gioca
ma non importa per gli mette consiste
sto gioco nel prendere le lettere quelle
che vedete sullo schermo io leggevo
premere sulla tastiera arrampicarmi solo
che è un casino perché tipo devo
mollarne e una aggrapparmi su un altro è
una minchia devi allungati e bravo alla
ragazzi voi non avete idea di quanto sia
difficile sta non sembra sembra semplice
ma vi giuro che è un casino per riuscire
a salire abbastanza velocemente visto
che siamo all'inizio questo per
invertebrati insomma c'è proprio proprio
no non è così difficile donna occhetto
regalo l'ho fatto un cazzo di m abbiamo
appena allora vediamo di riuscire a fare
un qualcosa di decente
e assurdo che ha fatto arrivare a 14
l'ultima volta impossibile comunque la
difficoltà ragazzi sto gioco più che
altro che ti si intrecciano le mani che
potessi mi fermerei le mani regala però
non posso perché devo prendere la mia
bellissima faccia sono disperata non
riuscire a fare una cosa cosa fai
ac ok allora piano piano che ce la posso
fare tavoli ccnl ciascun file pian piano
ci stiamo arrivando siamo 8 più o meno a
metà di quanto era arrivato l'ultima
volta perfetta ragazzi vi presento ugo
che è un uccello ragazzi che è il nostro
amico
no proprio per il cazzo ci rompere i
dall'inizio alla fine perché mi
ricordo l'ultima volta che ciò cristo
nato addosso stoppello di merda perché
fa una corsa che il ccc del ci tornerà
utilissima prima è che lui si mette si
mette sulle cose che noi dobbiamo sulle
lettere dove medici dobbiamo arrampicare
quindi non le possiamo più prendere
fantastico per esempio adesso
quella dove lui si è appoggiato
delicatamente il suo culo ma non posso
perché ci si è messo lui quindi non
posso farlo si prende a ginocchiate
finché non si toglie perfetto ha capito
subito e dopo di che posso prendere la
lettera se riesco ad allungarne
abbastanza perfetto tanti ragazzi stiamo
per arrivare a 14
comunque era un record che faceva
abbastanza schifo ma sono riuscito quasi
ad eguagliarlo buzzi onlus 14 e 7 record
per me questo già record ragazzi gay è
un punteggio d'arda mongo play dc però
per me va già bene in cassetti metti su
quanti schiaffi quant ischia non devi
toglierti dai se ti prendo ti faccia
arrosto cazzola lunghi articoli ma
guardi che non riescano allungarmi di un
metodo bravo bravissimo cazzo dove siamo
ma i ricordi ci sono perché partita sta
musica lega sta partendo una musica che
non mi piace mi mette tensione non
tranquilli cosa fa a raga non sulla pipì
non solo p è ma sei un testa di cazzo
allora togliti dai pennuto un
essere umano può mai rimanere incastrato
così ma che cazzo vabbè io non ho parole
regala la pena sì sì l'ho presa ragazzi
non sono mai arrivato a 24 assurdo no
devi toglierti pennuto dai tv togliti
dai fai qualcosa
ciò che a freccette non lo so ora che
non c'è come fai a non arrivarci le
allunga street
datemi un fucile
no no no no no no lo capisci che mi
serve quel punto che cazzo ci stai soft
o gli guarda che l'avevo preso a
quest'ora l'avevo preso sì sì sì sì sì
ragazzi sto arrivando ad un punteggio
assurdo non mi ha mai sociale a fermi un
attimo terminati o la s la regala sv se
devi toglierti la s va bene vada per lei
non importa la s siccome cazzo mice ecco
perfetto sono nella merda di più di
prima io mollo alla s perfetta associata
cosa fa rega ragazza la cui ce l'abbiamo
perché siamo a 30 metri casa hai fatto
trenta metri su circo che cazzo devo fà
fermi che non sto capendo dove davanti
togliti ugo ama lampeggiano qui cosi
quindi posso andare
ci possa andare ma posso fare ciò posso
fare sì sì regalati lati come ci arrivo
alla tv femi si si oh guarda lì che ti
devi allungare mamma mi allunga al tuo
braccio come se fosse il tuo bene
sì io santo cosa come sei messo amico
mio mamma mia ke kazzo sto facendo e
calmi
io devo mollare la p ok mica solo
sbagliato perfetto ci sento no no no no
ho detto no non si bravo grande se non
si crea è ugo buongiorno siamo arrivati
in un punto in cui io non punge e la 4
ae il mio massimo era 14 come cazzo sarà
arrivata 41 e 6 è una cosa che io non ci
posso credere un tentativo io io credevo
di farne 200 di arrivare a questo punto
di non arrivare mai a questo punto ma di
arrivare ad un punteggio decente dopo
mezz'ora invece al primo attentato nel
primo no però più o meno i primi
tentativi è un traguardo assurdo c'è una
cosa che non mi ricapiterà mai più nella
vita queste sono soddisfazioni cazzo è
anche da rete è stata una soddisfazione
a chiamarci porto a m clero siano 100
forse non lo so presumo siano 100
ragazzi per arrivare al 58 ci ho messo
mezz'ora se cadono 3 imprecare dal
mattino alla sera ma spero di non farlo
no no annuncia le ossa sto tizio regala
abbiate pazienza né possibile line
non penso mi porti da nessuna parte
tranne che a quel piccione di merda però
per la soddisfazione di romperli
vado lì sopra capitana no no
sticazzi che calcio gli ho dato
[Musica]
io mi da ragazzi mi devo lanciare mi
devo lanciare non ci arriverò mai
avvistano milan si vabbè però ragazzi
non ce la posso fare e la tensione
troppa semi lance cadeau ho fatto 53
metri a vuoto non ce la posso fare
[Musica]
[Applauso]
no sì no no no l'avevo preso o l'avevo
preso no ma non ce la fa ma
di merda alla fine spero ci siano due
belle tette sarebbe l'unica consolazione
di te dopo tutto sto casino c'è una cosa
pazzesca
che poi questo quasi tocca al pene cioè
fa cose bruttissime non ci arriverò mai
la z è un traguardo irraggiungibile
tranne adesso ci ho messo secoli ho
preso anche la z fantastico sono
traguardi gli y j ormai non temo nessuno
regala sono un professionista ma neanche
bear grylls saprebbe sky scalare una
montagna così ragazzi siamo orche ok
praticamente siamo arrivati ad un punto
dove che cosa fare qui ragazzi io ho
capito che cosa dovrei fare ma non
voglio farlo
ok non voglio farlo non voglio lasciarmi
per andare liscio lega vi prego non
fatemi fare questo con tutti mi piace
che mettetevi in questo momento mi fate
militato e coraggio è una giornata bella
ci posso provare
[Musica]
cazzo ragazzi ho fatto una cosa epica
ho fatto una cosa epica se io
muoio adesso ci rinuncio pazienza non fa
niente ma sono arrivato a un punto in
cui possa essere fiero di me stesso
cazzo un uomo senza cinghie senza
neanche le ossa perché non potrebbe
girare le braccia così riuscita a fare
un passo del genere ragazzina cosa
storica se solo penso che per arrivare
qua ci ho messo un'ora e mezza è seccato
li devo iniziare tutto daccapo e la cosa
mi mette mai mi sembra quasi che sia io
ad arrampicarmi se ti fosse se cado mi
incazzo uguale che va bene nella vita
reale non è che se cadi ti incazzi di
preoccupi giusto un po no no no no non
ragazzi basta va bene va bene il 66
metri e andava bene superare i 14 ho
fatto di più di quanto sperassi va bene
così non guarderò più né una montagna né
un cazzo di piccione per il resto della
mia vita questo ve lo posso assicurare
comunque ragazzi io concludo quindi
episodio al come al solito seguito è
piaciuta stato argomento mi piace anche
la pagina di facebook e come ogni video
tra tra descrizione delle quali siti
iscrivetevi riusciti per diavolo
proseguito perché da ragazzi